[موسيقى]
كل شيء فيه لا يوجد التحقيق في اي حاله في
اي قصه
هذه هي اخر نقطه سمح لنا بالتصوير فيها في
الجانب اليوناني من الحدود مع تركيا هذا
البحر من خلفنا تحول الى مقبره للعديد من
اللاجئين الذين يقصدون الوصول الى هنا
افواجا
ليست وحدها الامواج والظروف المناخيه هي
التي تحول دون وصولهم بل رجال ملثمين لا
تعرف هويتهم باتوا السد المنيعه لسد
اللاجئين في البحر والبر وفي النهار فمن
هؤلاء ومن يقف خلفه
[موسيقى]
جيش الظل
اسم يتردد صداه وافعاله في المناطق
الحدوديه بين اليونان وتركيا
قليله من تحدث عن هذا الجيش في ظل حاله
التعديم والاستهداف لمن يقترب من هذا
الملف
رجال الملثمون خارج نطاق الاجهزه الامنيه
الرسميه
لكنهم يعملون وفق خطه المحكمه والاهداف
المحدده
[موسيقى]
في هذا التحقيق تمكن ما خفي اعظم من رصد
تجربه احد المجندين في صفوف جيش الظل
والذي جند من قبل ضباط يونانيه وكشف كثير
من الغموض الذي ظل يلف هؤلاء الرجال
لسنوات العده
ما
تساعدوا اللي بيعمل مشاكل النهار جبتوه
كيف تصف ما يجري على الحدود اليونانيه
الان ضد اللاجئين يونيو
النور
الانتهاكات تتم بايدي رجال ملثمين مرتزقه
وعلى اعين اجهزه الامن الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
يوجد في الدمام
بروفين
بوجود الجيش
النقط والفول يا باي باي
في هذا التحقيق حصلنا على صور ولقطات عده
توثق انتهاكات مروعه لافراد جيش الظل ضد
اللاجئين في مناطق حدوديه داخل البحر وعلى
البحر
ابرزها عند الحدود مع اليونان
[موسيقى]
فلسطين المحتله ذهبنا من تركيا الى الحدود
نعم الى اوروبا ونبحث عن حياه جديده هناك
فقطعنا انها فقام بالامساك من البوليس
اليوناني وقام بتعذيب يعني قام بتعديل
بدار بضربهم يعني مبرح جدا
وقام يعني بالتعامل المائي بكل عموم وبعد
مده سبعه ايام وقام باخذ كل ما املك من
اموال
ومواه
قويه شخصيه قام به يعني بعد ما قام بدار
به يعني ضرب مبرح قام بترجع الى الحدود
التركيه اليونانيه
في هذه اللقطات الحديثه التي صورت خلال
عملنا على هذا التحقيق تظهر جثث لضحايا
بينهم اطفال تم انتشالهم من بحر ايجا بعد
اغراقهم عمدا من قبل ملثمين باشراف الامن
اليوناني
ر سالم
[موسيقى]
تظهر هذه اللقطات لاجئين ناجين تم انقاذهم
من قبل خفر السواحل التركي الذي وثق
عمليات الاغراق المتعمد لقواربهم الصغيره
منهم من تعرض لاصابات جسيما على ايدي
الملثمين
هنا في مدينه ادرنه التركيه قصدت مركز
ايواء اللاجئين المرجعين عنه عبر نهر في
المنطقه الفاصله بين تركيا واليونان
[موسيقى]
في داخل المركز التقيت باربعه اشخاص عادل
توه من الحدود احدهم هذا الرجل الفلسطيني
عمري
[موسيقى]
انا بسال الاولاد مش طالع اعيش في اوروبا
ومكيف عليها وربنا بالعكس انا كان فلسطين
ولا سوريا
لا بسوريا لاعبه فلسطين لا تدوم الخليجيه
استقبلتنا
التركيه بالاساس انا بندر على الاردن
السياره تقريبا 10 15 شخص شرطه شرطه
عسكريه
نزلنا بالسياره طالعونا على المستوى
اشخاص ثانيين ملثمين
التركي
كمان اكلنا ضرب منهم
يعني اذا واحد بطلع عليه
اذا واحد بده يعني
للبنات
احنا طول الطريق تحت الخوف
طلبنا منهم طلبنا ميه طلبنا اكل يعني تحت
الخوف ما نقدر يعني حتى النظر يقول لا
تطلع يعني هيك يعني ما يصير تطلع عليه ما
يصير يطلع علي هذا ما يصير اطلع عليه
طلعونا
على النار
النساء كان معي طفل وكان معي بنت صغيره
فما كان يقدروا ينزلوا بلشوا ضرب فيهم
يضربوهن ويزتون يعني نحنا ما عندنا مشكله
بالنهار نقدر نمشي حالنا ولكن معانا نساء
اطفال رضيع يا الله رضيه شايله بحضني عمره
اربع شهور ما يتخطا هون
يعني لا سمح الله لو كان النهر جاري نحن
كمان نروح فيها
في ناس لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله بس يعني
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
كتبنا حياه جديده انا بالنسبه الي كتب لي
حياه جديده
وبعد النار ليش ما اعطونا لجوه
سرقوا كل شيء منكم
حتى يعني
فتشوا القلب
شكلها
من الملابس تعمل هيك طبعا انت عارف تماما
انا عارف بلا انسانيه يعني بدك تعمل حركه
هيك وتقوم توقف
يعني
معلومه صادمه من بين افراد جيش الظل
الملثمين رجال عرب تمكنا من الوصول الى
احد الذين انخرطوا في جيش الظل خلال
الاشهر القليله الماضيه والاتصال به
شو طبيعه المهمات اللي كلفوكم فيها
نهر
ناخذ مثل همم ليفربول
تمام ومطلع الناس والعالم فيه ونرجعهم على
دقه التربيع ونرجع بعدين
باللسان في كل المهمات اللي بتقوم فيها
يعني
[موسيقى]
اهلا المشاكل بيقدم النهار جبت
اللافته ان الشخص الذي تواصلنا معه كان
احد اللاجئين الذين قصدوا اليونان بحرا
قبل ان يتم اعتقاله وينتهي به المطاف
مجندا في جيش الظل
[موسيقى]
الى العاصمه اليونانيه اثنان اتينا حاملين
معنا الادله والاتهامات
لمواجهه المسؤولين اليونانيين هنا حول ما
يسمى بجيش الظل
واجباري لاجئين على الانخراط فيه
قصدت وزاره شؤون الهجره اليونانيه سعيا
للقاء الرجل الذي ارتبط اسمه بالسياسات
اليونانيه في ملف اللاجئين والتي شهدت
تحولات بارزه خلال السنوات الاخيره
بعد اخذ ورد وافق الوزير يانسبيتراكس على
لقائنا والاجابه على تساؤلات تحقيق ما
خفيه اعظم
هل تقر سيد متراكس بعمليات الارجاع بالقوه
من قبل السلطات اليونانيه للاجئين على
حدودها
منظمات حقوق الانسان
الجيش
[موسيقى]
كريم
من الاسبوع
وين بيبول
هنا في مدينه اسطنبول
مع الاتحاد
[موسيقى]
امك
مطابقات ان شاء الله
اونسك
المصوره التي حصلنا عليها ووثقه انتهاكات
مروحه ضد اللاجئين في البحر
اليوناني يعملون على اغراق اللاجئين في
قارب المطاطي
وبعد ايام رصدت مقاطع اخرى انتشال عدد من
جثث هؤلاء اللاجئين عند الحدود مع تركيا
هناك حديث عن جيش الظل
على ارض اليونان على الحدود يمارس
انتهاكات فضيعه ضد اللاجئين هذه صور من
الحدود اليونانيه لملثمين يقومون باغراق
اللاجئين في البحر في النهر
[موسيقى]
هل اطلعت على هذه الصور
فندق فندق
زي عربي
[موسيقى]
عبد الوهاب
يعني
[موسيقى]
قناه
ارقام المفقودين في البحر وفي البر
متضاربه الاف المناسبات للبحث على
اللاجئين انقطعت اخبارهم في ظل حاله الصمت
الذي تلتزمه السلطات اليونانيه والوكاله
الاوروبيه لحرس الحدود والسواحل
يعني
اون
توشيبا
[موسيقى]
يوتيوب يوتيوب
ملثمين يمارسون اقصى وابشع الجرائم ضد
اللاجئينوفو
تنزيل
في مقابل نفي الوتركس تظهر هذه الوثيقه
مراسلات الى الحكومه اليونانيه من قبل
مؤسسه لايت هاوس التي وثقت حالات انتهاكات
من قبل رجال جيش الظل وقد تقدمت فعلا
بالادله التي بحوزتها لمؤسسه الشفافيه
اليونانيه
كمبيوتر
داونلود
من الماضي
تركيا
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
تجنيد للاجئين بالقوه وبالاجبار للعمل ضمن
جيش الملثمين على الحدود لارجاع اللاجئين
ووثقنا حاله بالادله
انت الوزير المختص عن شؤون اللاجئين هل
سمعت بهذا الاستخدام واجبار لاجئين على
انضمام لهذا الجيش
الظل لاكثر من شهره
يوفقان لحظه خروجهما من المعسكر اليونانيك
على الحدود مع تركيا والذي ضمهم مع عشره
اخرين خلال فتره جديده
هو احمد الذي كنا قد اجرينا معه لقاء
هاتفا خلال هذا التحقيق
بعد بحث و متحرك علمنا ان احمد غادر
اليونان متنقلا بين دول اوروبيه عده
وانتهى به المطاف في احدى عواصمها
نجحنا اخيرا في الوصول الى الشاب السوري
احمد الذي وافق على اجراء مقابله شرط عدم
الكشف عن هويته الحقيقيه او المكان الذي
يقيم فيه الان حفاظ على سلامته
[موسيقى]
احمد هل سمعته جيش الظل قبل ان تنضم اليه
وتعرض لي كثير بالمحاولات 900 موديل
[موسيقى]
نساء يعني مساؤه اطفال
اللي صدمني انا انه وصلنا بنصف النهار قال
لي قومي
قال لي لا ومنزله
قلت له لا ما في صاحب عريس
واحده عضوا في هذا الجيش اصبحت عضو في هذا
الجيش بعد اجبار بعد انتصار انا ما كنت
بدي اكون معهم ولكن خيروني بين 25 سنه
واضح جدا
عشر سنين بتاكل 25 سنه
اللي هي الفتره ان طالب تهون معنا بهذا
الشغل تسعه شهور 90 يوم
75 يوم ل 90 يوم ولكن اذا حولت انا على
السجن اقول
انت الوحيد
لماذا تم اختيارك انت تحديدا من قبل من
كانوا معك من اللاجئين لتكون ضمن
[موسيقى]
اللغه في اللغه التواصل
في اسلوب
وحتى كان واحد من الشروط اللي
يشترطها الضابط تبع المخابرات انه اي شخص
بده يجي جديد او بدون تلاقوا شخص جديد او
اي حاجه بده يجي جديد او حتى اذا بدنا
نلاقي حدا جديد لازم يكون يحكي لغه
انجليزيه حتى نقدر نتواصل حتى نقدر
والشرط الثاني انه ااه يكون
متفهم الموضوع يعني خلاص هذا هو الشغل
[موسيقى]
الموضوع
احمد ما عدد من رفاقه اللاجئين الذين
تجندوا في جيش الملثمين وهم داخل مركز حرس
الحدود اليوناني في بلده خيرو والتي تقع
في منطقه ايفرس التي خدم فيها احمد
بحسب احمد فان الضابط اليوناني الذي جند
احمد ورفاقه هو رفاييل فودانيكس وهو ضابط
في حرس الحدود اليوناني
تواصلنا معه عبر حسابه الشخصي على فيسبوك
للرد على الاتهامات الموجهه اليه لم يصلنا
منه رد حتى تاريخ بث هذا التحقيق عدد
افراد هذا الجيش بالمئات بالالاف الحدود
وكلهم كانوا في نقاط عسكريه تابعه للجيش
والشرطه
مباشر
الشرطه المهاجرين
بالاخير تسلم لنا اياهم من شان
المعلومات وانا عمليات تجديد اللاجئين
للانضمام الى جيش الملثمين هي منظمه
ومستمره وتطالب جنسيات مختلفه باشراف
مباشر من ضباط من المخابرات والشرطه
اليونانيه
هل اخذوا حد على جانب منكم من الموجودين
اخذوا حد لحاله
ومرجعهوش معكم من الاطراف اللي كانوا
موجودين
في واحد كان سوري والثاني يمكن مغربي
وين راحوا فيهم
من بين الذين قابلناهم في هذا التحقيق
الشاب التونسي محمد
اعتقلته السلطات اليونانيه مع زوجته بعد
نجاحهما في اجتياز الحدود اليونانيه ضمن
رحله لجوء مريره رفقه اخرين يقول محمد ان
ضباطا يونانيين عرضوا عليه العمل ضمن
مجموعات الملثمين هل تم العرض عليك
المرتزقه
[موسيقى]
بالقطار
كنا ثمانيه
حكم علينا عرض ان كان يعني هو واحد ملثم
مركز الشرطه
[موسيقى]
ابو كريم
75 يوم
كامله
لا تكشف عن هويتكم اي حدا حاول يعتدي
عليكم بقلب النهر بقلب البلون
حاول بقدر الامكان انه تحموا حالكم نحن ما
بنقدم لكم
اذا صار عليك شيء هذا الشيء بصير عليك انت
يعني ما يصير علينا
الجيش التركي
من اين كنتم تاكلون ومن معداتكم لبسكم
في فتره من الفترات كانوا يوصلوا
المهاجرين ما معهم اكيد اليوم
ما في مشاكل
فقط من اجل ورقه فقط
ما حدا يقرب عليه بس بعد الشهر
من الوثيقه التي منحتها السلطات اليونانيه
لاحمد مقابله عمله مع فريق الملثمين
الوثيقه مؤرخه في شهر يناير من عام 2021
وهي بمثابه تصريح بحريه التنقل في اليونان
لمده شهر واحد لانهاء ملف اللجوءه في
اليونان او في دوله اوروبيه اخرى
قالوا لي انه فتره ثلاثه شهور اوعك تحكي
انه انتبه تحكي لاي حدا انه انت كنت من
الكوماندوز
ممكن تشتغل معنا او انت كنت بتعرفنا اول
بتعرف اي حد
وحتى هددوني يعني انه اذا نحن سمعنا من اي
حدا انه انت حاكيه هالشخص هذا انه انا كنت
عم بشتغل معاهم نحن حنرجع الفكره بعد اخذ
الورقه راحت بدي اللجوء باليونان قال لي
مين حاله انت
وكل شيء معك
هذا الوصف الصحي
عام
في اي قصه في اي حادث تنفي كل هذه القصص
عبسي
ويسامحه
الخوف من نشر الحقائق عن هذا الملف يزداد
مع التعمق فيه
اعلاميون ومنظمات حقوقيه تم استهدافهم
لتناولهم وكشفهم اخبار عن جيش الظل وعن
اللاجئين
خلال عملنا على هذا التحقيق رفعت العديد
من القضايا على اعلاميين ومنظمات حقوقيه
تحدثت عن قضيه اللاجئين وتعامل السلطات
الاوروبيه معها
الصحفي اليونانيه
كشفت وثائق مسربه تعرض هاتفه للاختراق
والتجسس عليه من قبل المخابرات اليونانيه
بسبب نشاطه الصحفي في ملف الانتهاكات ضد
اللاجئين
كلاس نوفمبر
اخويا
اعلامي يوناني
لانه قام بقصه عن على الحدود اليونانيه تم
التجسس على هاتفه
الى الحدود
على حقيقته من على الارض
توجهنا الى جزيره ليسبوس اليونانيه
المحاديه للحدود التركيه وفي الطريق الى
المخيم مررنا بمخيم موريا القديم والذي
اصبح اطلالا كبير شاب فيه عام 2020
[موسيقى]
بعد تدقيق امني دخلنا الى مخيم كاراتيه
المحاط بحراسه المشدده
[موسيقى]
كم عدد اللاجئين في هذا المخيم
عربي com
[موسيقى]
اليونانيه انخفضت بشكل ملحوظ بالمقارنه مع
الاعداد التي سجلتها السنوات الماضيه
ولكن هناك من يقول روايه اخرى ان هذا
العدد وهذا وهذا الانخفاض الكبير في عدد
اللاجئين داخل المخيمات يعود الى عمليات
الارجاع القصر للاجئين وهي عمليات غير
قانونيه على الحدود سواء البريه او
البحريه
كان همم
[موسيقى]
خلال جولتنا في المخيم والتي اصطحابنا
فيها عدد من المسؤولين والمشرفين
اليونانيين تحفظ معظم من التقيناهم من
اللاجئين على الحديث عن تفاصيل الرحلات
اللجوء
[موسيقى]
محلنا خلال التحقيق بالتصوير داخل المخيم
فقط وتم منعنا من الوصول الى المناطق
الحدوديه بحجه انها مناطق عسكريه مغلقه
[موسيقى]
ذا فويس
والسايند
في الوقت الذي كنا فيه على ارض اليونان
تصاعدت حده الخطاب بين كل من اثنى وانقره
وتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات على اصعده عده
وفي قلب الخلاف ملف اللاجئين لم يتوقف
الامر عند التصريحات بل تعداه الى تحركات
عسكريه على الجانبين
في الجانب التركي من الحدود رافقت وحده من
خفر السواحل التركي الذي زاد مؤخرا من
وتيره جولاته المكثفه في بحر ايجا غير
بعيد عن الجزر اليونانيه
[موسيقى]
سلاح الاندرويد
هم نقدر بشر بوصه
[موسيقى]
يعني
جديد
رمضان تشكيله
طور هذه العلاقه مع اليونان الى تصعيد
عسكري او توتر عسكري الجميع
[موسيقى]
طريق الموت يعني
انت رايح تموت بطريق
والله اعلم
حقي يعيشك انسى
انا انسان بدي اعيش
[موسيقى]
الم تدرك احمد انما قمت به يصنف بانه
جريمه وعمل غير قانوني
بس اللي قاموا في الشرطه كمان الضابط
الشرطه
من ضفه اللجوء الى ضفه الارتفاع
بهم المطاف مجندين فيما يسمى بجيش الظلم
اجنده سياسيه
وغطاء امني لجرائم منظمه ترتكبه هنا على
حدود اوروبا تحت سمعه وبصري صناعي قرارها
فصول من الانتهاكات المروعه والمستمره
تكشف بعضها لكن ما خفيه اعظم
[موسيقى]